Donald Trump appeared yesterday on the
Chris Stiegel podcast I have no idea
what that is but these are the sorts of
interviews that the failed former
president is now relegated to doing
Trump's brain broke it it acutely broke
it almost made a noise like a clanking
noise when it broke that's a joke Trump
repeating the now widely debunked
conspiracy theories about the attacker
of Paul Pelosi Trump saying that he once
made rough statements on Jewish what
does that mean I have no idea what the
hell this guy is talking about look at
the breakdown
of this man's brain starting with the
first clip Trump asked about the assault
on Paul Pelosi listen to what Trump said
how do you read what's happened in the
Pelosi household in San Francisco over
the weekend by the way why do all of
these right Wingers
have the Alex Jones voice Batman's a
loser why do they all talk like Alex
Jones topic for a different day well
it's a weird things going on in that
household in the last couple of weeks uh
you know I probably you and I are better
not talking about it because but the
last it seems was broken from the inside
to the out lie and you know that was so
it wasn't a break-in it was a breakout I
don't know you know you hear the same
things I do yeah the 911 tape seems to
suggest that uh they that he knew the
identity of the guy right yeah yeah uh
that's a lot of bad stuff I'm not a fan
of Nancy Pelosi but what's going on
there is very sad yeah I just it seems
to me there would be security evidence
of this there just seems to be more of
this story would it would it be safe to
say this is I think more than the
traffic accident
on Republicans or you sir I mean how
absurd clearly this was a deranged man
we know that much
yeah it's the whole thing is crazy I
mean if there's even a little bit of
Truth to what's being said
it's crazy but if the window was broken
in and it was strange that the cops were
the you know standing there practically
they didn't from the moment it all took
place so listen
Trump repeated these claims yesterday
November 1st after we already had
information about all of these claims
the attacker himself confirmed all of
what we now know to be true uh the cops
didn't just stand there they very
quickly found the guy the glass was not
broken From the Inside Out yes there
were pieces of Glass on the outside
imagine taking a hammer to a glass
window every time you pull it back
towards you to hammer it again you pull
a little bit of glass out it's not a big
shock that there was glass on the
outside uh Pelosi didn't say I know the
guy it appears as though in order to
keep the guy calmer while on the phone
with 9-1-1 he said something like my
friend here but he did not literally
mean I know the guy the guy is known to
me the attacker already said he had had
no previous contact with Pelosi
um Pelosi was in his underwear because
he sleeps in his underwear and it was
two in the morning there were security
cameras that recorded every single one
of these lies already debunked but this
is nothing then during the Chris Stiegel
interview they get to the topic of Kanye
West and Trump says
he made rough statements on Jewish
I I know you're saying David are you are
you missing a word there what do you
mean roughs what did we listen do you
think Kanye West is getting a fair Shake
I always thought after he aligned with
you even for a while uh he was a Marked
Man no matter what he said or done since
uh he you know he's been on the Tucker
Carlson show as you know how do you read
Kanye West these days well I I was very
honored when I was because I didn't know
him that well but I liked him I always
got along with him very well and I was
very honored in a sense because he uh
you know he said all those great things
about being Tucker Carlson
uh by the way that's what matters if he
said good things about Trump Trump's
going to defend him made some statements
rough statements uh on Jewish rough
statements on Jewish
I might once made rough statements on an
Apple I was sitting on the Apple it was
weird you heard them and you know them
well yes and uh they're saying that that
was the reason
uh so then you ask well would it have
been the same thing if he didn't say all
those good things about Trump you know
you just don't know
um
he'll be fine I think he'll be fine he's
a very different kind of a guy yes and
uh it was very interesting to hear
mataka Carlson because you know you
never hear him in long sentences right
they also cut out a bunch of
anti-Semitic stuff from the Tucker
interview too he was actually very sharp
and very uh very smart I was I was
impressed by a lot of what he said well
they talked about life he talked about
health these are things that he feels
the black community is being lied to
about those things he does he feels it
and and it's it's all about what have
you done for me lately Kanye has praised
Trump so Trump's gonna say listen he
made rough statements on Jewish whatever
that means but he's pretty brilliant I
liked a lot of the things he said Trump
confirms he won't go back to Twitter in
the context of his own platform truth
essential yeah if I go on there what
would happen to truth I don't know you
know I I don't know but but the answer
is I'm not doing it right I won't go
back on and but I find truth to be much
better it's smarter it's friendlier and
also can be very nasty yeah oh yes
especially if they get against you a
little bit even your own people if they
disagree with something you did they
Trump's talking about vaccines there
yeah we got some smart ones but it's
it's tremendous and it was number one
for the last couple of weeks it's
incredible how well yeah so Donald Trump
his own platform which he often gets the
name wrong of Truth Central he says he's
sticking with truth and not going back
on Twitter and lastly Trump playing with
the supply chain games remember when
Trump used to love to say the cupboards
were bare and all this different stuff
now he's saying there's no turkeys this
shouldn't be in this country and I can't
help but feel like it's purposeful sir
sir is that you read
well it's certainly a terrible thing and
it certainly shouldn't be and supply
chain shouldn't be in this country
either I mean Pierce you know just basic
supply chain now I understand you can't
get turkey you can't get turkey now
Trump understands folks listen this
interview was on November 1st who is
buying a turkey on November 1st for a
November 24th Thanksgiving now sure if
you've got a huge freezer or something I
know some people will buy the turkey on
November 1st every place I'm seeing is
scheduling the turkey pickups for like
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday of
Thanksgiving week that's number one and
then number two I've just been to two
different grocery stores this week
they're filled with turkeys there's
turkeys bursting out of everywhere I
tried to get avocados there were turkeys
there I tried to get you know uh I tried
to get whatever anyway there's turkeys
everywhere at this point in time Trump
relegated
to completely frothing at the mouth
friendly interviews on podcasts no one's
ever heard of Chris stigl and he still
doesn't make any sense let's keep
fighting this right-wing nuttery by
growing Progressive Independent Media as
far as we can if you are watching these
clips on YouTube and you are not
subscribed please hit that subscribe
button I know many of you say David sir
I see all your Clips I don't need to
subscribe do me the favor because
there's almost three million of you who
watch the clips but don't subscribe if
we were to get to 2 million YouTube
subscribers it would be an
accomplishment held only by The Young
Turks in the Progressive media space
help us get there hit that subscribe
button I'll give you an update on our
progress next week
I want to tell you about something I use
every day because it simplifies my life
I don't have hours to mathematically
plan every meal or take multiple
different supplements and vitamins to
make sure I'm getting exactly what I
want to get every single day and the
solution is our sponsor athletic greens
product ag1 I've been taking ag-1 for
over a year it's just great it's just
one small scoop of ag1 in the morning I
get 75 vitamins minerals probiotic all
from whole food sources it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's no
extraneous stuff making wild claims I
drink it straight with water because I
like the taste you can put it in a
smoothie or juice or a shake it's just
simple ag1 is a sustainable routine
because it's just one scoop in the
morning takes one minute once a day I
know I'm covered in getting what I want
I can really be sure that I am properly
nourishing my body with the things I'm
trying to get that's the most important
part athletic greens knows I'm a vitamin
D guy I've talked about in the winter I
take vitamin D to make up for the lack
of sun exposure I take that every day as
well I've mentioned it on the show and
so athletic greens is giving you a free
year of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase when you
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below